Donald Trump's former national security
adviser Michael Flynn has lawyers
because he's likely getting indicted and
he through his lawyers has communicated
with Donald Trump's legal team and
Flynn's lawyers are saying hey you know
what we can no longer discuss the robert
muller investigation with you any longer
and this could be a potentially major
story a major wrinkle in the Trump
Russia investigation that Robert Muller
is currently involved in a special
prosecutor a few possibilities about
what this means the most interesting and
likely and compelling possibility is
that Michael Flynn is now what is
described as fully cooperating with
prosecutors
Robert molars investigators and
prosecutors and that Michael Flynn's
lawyers are trying to work out a deal
for Michael Flynn that would include
talking about what insiders up to and
including Donald Trump may have done in
the lead-up to the election of Donald
Trump and possibly even after previously
Michael Flynn's lawyers had been sharing
information with Paul with Donald
Trump's lawyers and they had this sort
of agreement that they would share
information and that agreement is now
over and this could either represent or
signal a huge advancement in the reach
of Robert Muller's investigation into
Trump Russia collusion the possible
charges against Michael Flynn are very
wide ranging and multiple legal experts
are expecting a Michael Flynn indictment
any time but Flynn is still a figure in
this that depending on the degree of his
cooperation could set off just a major
domino effect of really big indictments
very very close to the Trump White House
and when you look at the circumstances
of Michael Flynn you realize from the
point of view of a prosecutor how ripe
Flynn is for being leveraged might be a
word that's used flipped might be
another word that's used Flynn was
remember operating as an unregistered
foreign agent and working for Donald
Trump's White House and Michael Flynn's
own son is now can being considered
vulnerable to indict
which if Flynn is a normal person he
would want to do whatever he can to help
his son avoid getting indicted on
criminal charges and I was reading on
some right-wing forums yesterday people
online saying what a tough situation
Michael Flynn must be and do you stay
loyal to the great Trump or do you stay
loyal to your family if Flynn is a
normal person this is a no-brainer right
Donald Trump has been the opposite of
loyal to Michael Flynn Trump just isn't
a loyal guy to anybody but himself and
sometimes to his immediate family and in
these situations it's often the cover-up
that gets you rather than the original
crime or sometimes it's not even a crime
sometimes you start with a misdeed or
something that is odd or less than ideal
and not a crime but it's the cover-up or
the lying to investigators that
ultimately takes you down and Flynn's
position is one that he could know where
the bodies are buried proverbial I think
I'm speaking proverbially but when one
never knows and to me this is way more
interesting than paw mana for its
possible cooperation because Paul
Manafort
was Trump's campaign chairman manager
before Donald Trump was elected Michael
Flynn worked in the White House Michael
Flynn worked for the current
administration and realistically might
know about criminal acts that might have
been committed by everyone from Trump
and pens to Kushner and that to me is
still one of the most interesting
questions how much did Mike Pence know
and when did pence know it because in
the back of his mind if you're pence you
must be thinking I've got an opportunity
maybe to be President of the United
States here if Donald Trump is impeached
or resigns if Pence is actually separate
from whatever Trump Ruscha stuff took
place if Pence is complicit in it or
knew about it or participated in the
cover of a cover-up of it he may go down
if and when Trump ultimately goes down
and I just want to remind everybody very
interesting little detail President
Obama told Donald Trump not to hire
Michael Flynn and Trump hired Michael
Flynn and it may ultimately be Michael
Flynn that brings the Trump house of
cards crashing
and that that's not a detail we should
forget because Trump Trump's mo the
entire time that he has been president
has been undo or ignore or go against
anything that President Obama did and
it's very funny and and probably sad in
some way interesting nonetheless
that following President Obama's advice
at least when it came to Michael Flynn
could have reduced the amount of risk to
Trump in his administration pretty
significantly we'll see we'll continue
to follow it the video you just watched
was made possible by support from you
please go to patreon.com slash david
pakman show you can make a pledge of as
little as one dollar per month and every
dollar helps to support the work that
we're doing particularly in light of the
YouTube ad boycott which has been really
bad